hey guys guess what I have bronchitis
and that is absolutely terrible timing
considering everything that we've been
trying to do this past week and not that
that we haven't been successful but if
you've noticed this past few days we've
been trying to do the 12 days of
Christmas all starting with the actual
video 12 days of Christmas and it's
something that we've wanted to do for a
while now is something we've been
planning and it's something we've been
moderately successful at All Things
Considered even though I have been
extremely ill the past few days I've had
a fever body aches chills just general
tiredness and my voice flipping in and
out my voice actually came back for a
little bit and I was able to record a
little bit but I went at it too hard
and yesterday I couldn't speak in more
than a hushed whisper I wouldn't have
even been able to do this vlog if I
hadn't spend the whole day quiet and in
fact I kind of got everybody else sick
Tyler Ethan Catherine and Amy I got them
all sick because of whatever the hell I
brought back from the UK and if you
don't know what bronchitis is it's an
infection of the bronchial tubes in your
lungs it means you're sick and feel
terrible and you generally cough up a
bunch of unpleasant all that
disgusting this aside I am really happy
with what we've been doing we have been
like nose to the grindstone working our
asses off despite everything I'm so
proud of everybody else and I'm proud of
myself that I've been able to keep going
because it's been this drive to commit
to this thing that I wanted to do the 12
days of Christmas and we've been doing
it very successfully albeit I mentioned
with a few tweaks here and there like we
wanted to do more challenge based stuff
we wanted to do more things like the
gingerbread house building challenge and
we had like building a snowman challenge
present wrapping challenge Christmassy
decorating challenge all with twists
that make them very interesting and we
weren't able to do that because my voice
just completely shut down on me it was
so weird because usually when I get sick
I get six for one or two days maybe
three my voice goes out because he's
like throat infection and then it comes
back and it I was sick my throat went
out and then it came back and in that
span I recorded as much as I could
but I went out so hard my my voice just
kind of exploded on me and like I said I
absolutely couldn't talk yesterday and
it's still a little rough today because
my high range is not quite there and
that's really sad because I want to tell
you guys what we had planned to do all
of this was going to be leading up to on
Christmas Day we were actually going to
make a full cover song of silent night
and I was going to sing it and I'm
really sad that that's not able to
happen because I literally don't have a
voice it was so frustrating to have this
thing come now when we were also
preparing to all go back to our families
we're leaving in two days all to go back
to our families to celebrate Christmas
and we were trying to get ahead on
recording
videos and we've been moderately
successful in that but nowhere near as
much as we would have been if I had not
brought back sickness from the UK so I
want to say thank you everybody for your
support I mean I've been really happy
with the videos that we've been able to
put out thus far anyway and I'm really
happy that you guys have responded so
well to it like the the gingerbread
house building challenges probably one
of the funniest videos that we've made
in a long time and that was in that
narrow window where my voice actually
came through for me and I'm super happy
that we were able to do that and I'm
super happy that you guys actually
enjoyed the improv that we've been doing
like the change game in the whose line
game we've actually got two more of
those that we have recorded that I was
going to save for a lot longer but now
that I'm sick and I'm still a little
sick I'm starting to feel better but my
throat is still thrashed
unfortunately so I'm going to give it
one more day to recover this vlog is the
only thing I'm going to record today and
then we're just going to be editing the
day and hopefully tomorrow we can work
on some more cool stuff but I don't know
there's very little time left and we are
back for the holidays so what I might do
actually no this is what I'm going to do
I have to make a judgment call here for
the next few days it's going to be one
video day but they are going to be the
Christmas theme videos we do have a few
of those still in the pipeline
for you guys to see and hopefully
hopefully those will be coming out
regularly at noon for the next few days
and then later this week on Friday it's
not a Saturday but it's Friday is our
charity livestream where we're going to
be raising money for Toys for Tots
that's going to be right here on the
channel starting at 10:00 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time so it's going to be
starting earlier than we did for the
last livestream because I'm live in LA
but I'm going back home to Cincinnati to
see my friends and family which is
something that I'm very much looking
forward to but in the next few days you
got some special Christmas themed stuff
that is both interesting hilarious and
absolutely disgusting and I can't wait
to show you guys what we have in store
so thank you everybody so much for being
so patient and understanding and for
being so accommodating in the like in
the chaos of the past few days and so
many people were telling me just to rest
but I couldn't stop I had to keep going
and we had to keep recording because I
knew that we had to make this thing
happen we are committed to doing it we
are committed to the 12 days of
Christmas and then after that we are
staying with her family and friends
until the new year and then we all come
back January 3rd or 4th or I can't
remember what day specifically but then
next year rolls around and it's going to
be an amazing year oh and also little
little sneak peek I know every we've
been hinting at bloopers and we've been
mentioning bloopers and you guys have
been demanding bloopers for the various
sketches and stuff that we've done we
actually started compiling a mega
compilation of bloopers it's up to 30
minutes of bloopers and when we were
watching it back
we were just dying on the floor laughing
at our own stupidity of this huge
enormous compilation of bloopers so we
think that's going to be an excellent
New Year's video for you guys to look
back on the things that we've been
making and laugh at our horrible
mistakes so you have that to look
forward to so mark your calendars for
the charity livestream I hope y'all have
had a wonderful December thus far and I
hope you could to see your friends and
families this December Christmas
whatever you celebrate I hope you have a
wonderful
holiday now I'm gonna give my voice a
rest we've got a few other things to
film the day that shouldn't be too
demanding but either way it's going to
be an awesome Christmas and thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye